fait frémir dans son ancien
quartier de Manhattan.
"Des gens mauvais qui doivent
"De la cruauté pure,
vait être révélée",
selon cette résidente.
mouvements comme #MeToo,
on arrive à les identifier
et à les condamner.
- Ghislaine Maxwell est un pur
produit de la haute sociét
britannique. Fille d'un magnat
de la presse mégalomane,
royauté dans son carnet
d'adresses.
Ghislaine Maxwell rencontre
hissime homme d'affaires
Jeffrey Epstein. Ensemble,
ils côtoient Donald Trump,
Bill Clintonet le prince Andrew.
Elle baigne dans l'opulence,
en échange de qu
... Pendant 10 ans,
Ghislaine Maxwell aurait recruté
que 14 ans pour les livrer
à son partenaon partenaon parte,
prétendu prédateur sexuel.
de Jeffrey Epstein, près de
Centra son ranch
ou à son domaine de Palm Beach,é
des filles souvent vulnérables
rétexte d'offrir des
massages à l'homme d'affaires
en éch
de dollars. Mais une fois
arrivé piège
se serait refermé sur elles.
Ghislaine Maxwe
elle-même participé
à d
selon la poursuite.
La femns, accusée
de crimes sexuels concernant
quatre
clâme son innocence.
Son pdevant jury pourrait
être la dernière chance de faire
la lumière sur les crimes
puissant, mort en prison,
s après son arrestation
en 2019.
Me MATTHEW J. GALLUZZO,
- Ce serait très difficile,je cr
de dire que c'était tout Epstein
et maintenant, cette affaiir
Epstein. Et elle se considèreco.
- Ghisère les barreaux
depuis 17 mois. Son procès
pourrait durer six semaines.
Ici Geneviève Garon,